[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español en la que damos la palabra a
artistas políticos deportistas hombres y
mujeres de las ciencias las artes el
mundo de la política y también de la
sociedad civil hoy vamos a viajar a perú
a la región de cuzco donde se localiza
la célebre ciudadela de machu picchu
declarada en 1983 patrimonio mundial de
la humanidad por la unesco buscó un
pulmón turístico del país andino pero
también un lugar donde se presentan
enormes conflictos socioambientales nos
acompaña jean paul benavente gobernador
de la región de cuzco y también
presidente de la asamblea nacional
regional de gobernadores de perú jean
paul benavente bienvenido a esta escala
en parís muchas gracias braulio un
saludo a quienes te siguen en radio
francia internacional
estamos acá a vuestras órdenes
cusco es una región andino amazónica
muchas gracias jean paul benavente usted
fue elegido en 2019 como gobernador de
esa región decíamos pulmón turístico de
perú pero también en un año se produjo
la pandemia cómo han vivido ustedes
situación bueno comentarte que de un
momento a otro la plaza central de cusco
la plaza de armas el mismo machu picchu
se vio vacía se vio que ha sido
completamente vacía sin turistas y
obviamente en el tema sanitario en el
tema de salud hubo un impacto fuerte en
mi país en mi región porque
estructuralmente había digamos algunas
deficiencias y debilidades además de
atravesar esa crisis sanitaria hemos
atravesado una crisis política y
económica que hoy día obviamente estamos
buscando una reactivación económica de
una reactivación del turismo la
situación ha vuelto a una cierta
normalidad la machu picchu la zona se ha
vuelto a abrir y como era de esperarse
ha habido una afluencia masiva de miles
de turistas para sólo en el primer
trimestre de este año más de 220 mil
turistas han llegado a esa zona como
están viviendo precisamente ahora esta
recuperación y han vuelven bueno
inmediatamente en el mismo año de la
pandemia de 2020 hacia el último
trimestre logramos obtener un sello safe
travel
la organización mundial del turismo para
poder convocar y animar el turismo
internacional pero también sobre todo
sobre vivir con el turismo interno el
turismo nacional a partir de eso estamos
retornando digamos a los datos y a los
números y a las cifras prepandémica
ahora mismo nos encontramos y esperamos
cerrar el año con 60 70 por ciento de la
cantidad de turistas que llegaban en
2019 y el objetivo según entiendo es
llegar claro midiendo muy bien los
flujos de turismo llegar a más de un
millón doscientos mil turistas por año
mucho más en el 2019 nosotros ya
teníamos un millón seiscientos mil
turistas en cusco en mi región este y a
partir de ello obviamente queremos
superar y para eso tenemos que trabajar
mucho en las condiciones de conectividad
pero también de conservación y
preservación de nuestro patrimonio
cultural y natural
jean-paul el departamento de cusco es
rico precisamente
las joyas arqueológicas que guarda pero
al mismo tiempo es muy rico también por
materiales y materias primas que existen
allí minerales y al mismo tiempo se
presenta en una enorme cantidad de
conflictos sociales concretamente en el
área de la minería que ha hecho su
gobierno para resolver este tipo de
conflictos sobre todo para prevenirlo en
base a los temas de las potencialidades
y riquezas que tenemos en nuestra región
no solamente como dice son estos
atractivos culturales esta herencia y
patrimonio cultural que tenemos sino
también un tema natural y en medio de
ello están los hidrocarburos de camisea
que es la fuente principal de
abastecimiento de energía en mi país y
obviamente el tema de la minería que
confluye todo un corredor minero el cual
nos ubica en segundo lugar en
latinoamérica en producción de cobre y
otros minerales al respecto se han
suscitado al alrededor de estas
industrias extractivas conflictos
sociales sobre los cuales en el mary en
mérito al diálogo y a la posibilidad de
generar una gobernanza en nuestra región
con las comunidades hemos logrado ir
digamos
resolviendo y coordinando con las
comunidades no obstante este es un tema
de competencia nacional sintiéndolo a un
nivel de gobierno nacional que debe de
intervenir y hasta ahora hemos visto
digamos una poca actuación no ha habido
soluciones concretas al tema pero igual
al menos en lo que nos ha tocado hemos
logrado impulsar para que estas
comunidades puedan coordinar con las
empresas mineras y se haga obviamente
una propuesta de minería responsable
fondos sociales que ayuden a que
convivan en armonía en este tipo de
industrias extractivas es un tipo de
conflictividad que efectivamente se
tiene que resolver a nivel nacional
donde hay muchos juegos políticos sin
duda alguno en no obstante el cusco es
la tercera región si bien entiendo donde
se presentan más tipo de conflictos de
este tipo así es por la naturaleza misma
están algunos enclaves mineros que
pertenecen a mi región y hay otro que
depende por qué recorrer ese el corredor
es el tránsito
pero digamos esa conflictividad se da
porque se requiere una actuación más
firme de hablar con autoridad como
estado pero también en la posibilidad de
aperturar un diálogo en el cual las
comunidades se vean antes atendidas y
podamos llevar desarrollo a esas partes
de mi región
jean-paul meramente recientemente hubo
protestas en la región de cuzco los
habitantes de algunas de las zonas que
comprenden este importante departamento
denunciaron la contratación de
extranjeros para jugar en los conflictos
territoriales que se están desarrollando
y concretamente acusaban segunda esto a
personas de origen venezolano que tan
cierto es esto que nos puede decir a
este propósito lo que tengo que decir es
que los problemas los estamos
resolviendo
particularmente el estado peruano y las
distintas instancias de gobierno se ha
habido la intromisión de algunas
personas ajenas a mi país obviamente eso
ha sido resuelto ha sido resuelto y
entiéndase de que más bien
en el mérito del diálogo y el
cumplimiento de los acuerdos porque eso
es no generarse reglas generarse
determinadas instituciones allí y en ese
marco y resolviendo cree confirma la
presencia detrás y se ha habido una
confirmación de ellos pero obviamente
este lo que digo es que lo más
importante de una decisión región es si
es darle solución cumpliendo los
compromisos tanto las empresas como el
estado peruano solución es uno de los
temas a los que usted ha dedicado
bastante tiempo decíamos es además de
ser gobernador de cusco presidente de la
asamblea nacional de gobiernos
regionales evidentemente están en
contacto con todos los otros
gobernadores que evaluación hacen
ustedes de la administración del
presidente pedro castillo bueno hacemos
la evaluación que es un gobierno muy
debilitado quizás por los ataques que ha
recibido y también por sus propios
méritos y lo que queremos ahora es
coadyuvar a que más bien se pueda
generar un proceso de aceleración de
inversiones hay una necesidad importante
en perú y creo en muchos países del
mundo en reactivar su economía en
generar empleo ingresos y para eso hay
que apalancar la inversión privada que
justamente si llega a un país es porque
hay menos ruido político no pero con
todo ese ruido que hay en mi país
obviamente se está estancando el
crecimiento de inversión privada y por
lo que nos toca a nosotros como
gobernadores es impulsar más bien la
inversión pública sobre la cual hay que
generarle
conectividad servicios básicos cerrar
brechas sociales de acceso a agua
educación a salud etcétera y carreteras
para impulsar por ejemplo temas como el
que estamos hablando ahora del turismo
es decir usted es un gobierno con muchos
problemas son 11 meses de la presidencia
de pedro castillo ha cambiado cinco
veces a sus ministros uno de los
gabinetes apenas duró 72 horas usted ha
planteado concretamente en abril pasado
un pacto de alcance nacional dijo usted
para superar la crisis concretamente
cuáles serían esos mecanismos para
superar esa situación de inestabilidad
que vive desde hace varios pero hay
cerca de 20 años que se ha logrado
gestar una institución que se llama el
acuerdo nacional donde participan
distintas instancias de gobierno de
distintos sectores y partidos políticos
así como la academia así como los
colegios profesionales el sector privado
el sector agrario los trabajadores y
nuestra propuesta era que en el marco de
ese acuerdo nacional se puedan resolver
tres o cuatro cosas uno que obviamente
afecta a los países y particularmente al
mío es el tema de la corrupción y una un
deslinde el contundente del presidente
en esos aspectos era para nosotros
importante luego animar a que haya una
apertura a convocar a distintos
profesionales que puedan integrar las
carteras ministeriales con ello darle
tranquilidad y estabilidad y
gobernabilidad del país y la siguiente
obviamente ponernos a trabajar
conjuntamente con el congreso de la
república que es el otro poder del
estado que genera este conflicto y por
lo tanto ahí lo que nosotros entendíamos
es que en vez de estar preocupados en
una vacancia del presidente era mejor
darle una salida porque ni uno ni el
otro quiere irse entonces es mejor
tenemos una salida en unidad nacional
generando reformas
económicas y políticas que hacen falta
hoy día pero usted estima que hay el
riesgo que el presidente pedro castillo
no acabe su mandato programado para el
2006 nos preocupa nos preocupa que
esta situación se pasaría a realizarse
no no obstante se se ha visto estos días
hay algunas evidencias en las cuales
podría poner en riesgo este tema no
continuar ero
pero también este alguien decía que es
este que a esta crisis la salida es que
no hay salida es decir que todos quieren
quedarse pero sin embargo quieren seguir
en crisis por lo tanto lo que nosotros
hemos señalado si ya no hay más salida
lo único que te queda es unidad nacional
y poder trabajar de la mano volvamos al
foco de cusco del que usted es
gobernador y la situación ecológica
evidentemente está afectando al mundo
entero en el caso de perú según estudios
se observa que el 20 por ciento de la
superficie de los glaciares se ha
derretido en los últimos 30 años como
enfrenta su gobierno esta situación
sabiendo que también es un problema de
carácter nacional como enfrentando pues
si así es es un tema de preocupación
mundial espero que la cob 26 puede hacer
algo más de lo que ha acordado a hacer
pero sí sin embargo este hace dos años
más o menos hemos sufrido por ejemplo un
aluvión un deslizamiento de uno de los
nevados más importantes que el shell
salcantay este año también hay otro
nevado que ha tenido deslizamientos y
nos preocupa la pérdida de los glaciares
en nuestro país para eso lo que estamos
haciendo son trabajos de siembra y
cosecha de aguas que significa
forestación y reforestación en las
cumbres y para hacer un trabajo más
adecuado en las cabeceras de cuenca no
nos queda otra cosa porque el tema del
impacto
este sobre el medio ambiente es global y
por lo tanto el calentamiento global
también está implicando a que nuestros
glaciares se pongan en riesgo mientras
tanto nuestra tarea es generar el
ecosistema mínimo
para garantizar por lo menos la
protección a nuestras grandes cumbres
pues estamos llegando ya al final de
esta escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecerle a jean paul benavente en
gobernador de la región de cuzco perú su
presencia en estos estudios muy amable
de habernos acompañado a ustedes les
damos una cita la próxima semana aquí en
otra fiscal en parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]